[Music]
it has been my privilege to have been
associated with the tremendous
organization the Canadian Institute for
Advanced Research who had the precedence
to begin a program in cosmology
recognizing that these questions that we
ask of the universe are questions that
can in fact be answered and for three
decades one's seen transformation after
transformation of the subject and our
program has evolved accordingly never
more so for discoveries than this past
five-year period of the program which is
what we're mostly focusing on today the
universe as we look around us here in
this room on the earth the galaxies and
out into the many galaxies that we see
around us looks very complex and it is
very complex the thing that we've
learned is that the beginnings of all of
that are tremendously simple and I'm
going to try and explain to you how we
learned about that simplicity and how
that simplicity has evolved into
complexity what is the driving force for
that it is the force of gravity it
naturally happens that one evolves from
simplicity to complexity if we look to
the extremely large future of the
universe rate at the moment our best bet
is that it will go to a state of extreme
simplicity once again and then we're
also trying to look at the earliest
moments of time and our belief is that
it that also is extremely complex so the
complex equation I'm putting to you now
as we go from complex to simple to
complex to simple a very interesting
philosophical view of the universe one
of the nuggets that we have learned over
these three decades and mainly within
the past two decades is that the
universe is made up of not just the
ordinary matter that you know and love
that you're made of that the air is made
of etcetera but the galaxy exists in the
form that it does and is being held
together predominantly by this
mysterious entity called dark matter we
call it dark matter because it is not
apparently radiating although it might
interact somewhat that's very important
for us but you can also think of dark in
the sense of mysterious and it is truly
dark matter it is mysterious and we
don't know what it is right now although
we're trying to find it but it has an
amount which is about six times that on
average in the universe of the ordinary
matter or five times lest you think that
this is only something that is going on
way out there way beyond we think that
our best bets for the dark matter that
it's here with us in this room passing
through you as we speak with a speed of
about 200 kilometers per second and very
very very rarely it's interacting with
you and so you are yourselves detectors
of dark matter among the best bets for
the dark matter is that there would be
roughly speaking one every twenty
centimeters or so so it's got nothing
similar to the density of ordinary
matter and air but if you go in too far
space then the dark matter dominates by
amounts that are of order six to one we
discovered something else we aren't very
good at naming names but we always used
the word adjective dark dark energy
so Dark Matter holds the galaxies
together
Dark Matter has a different rule to play
and it became dominant at fairly late
times as the universe goes and it causes
the galaxies not just to move away from
each other but to actually accelerate
away from each other and accelerate with
an increasing rate and that is something
if it's completely true allows us to
forecast our far far future which is
sort of like what people used to call a
heat death where we in the galaxy will
become quite isolated from all other
galaxies you don't have to worry this is
in an immortal phrase of of Carl Sagan
billions and billions and billions of
years downstream and when I say billions
I mean very many billions so this is the
basic simplicity of what makes up the
universe and then an issue is how did
all of the structure in the universe
arise and what we have learned again and
the story that I'm going to be telling
you is that that there are just a few
parameters that we need to have measured
in order to have understood how things
are arose we're going to begin at the
earth you know maps of the earth but I'm
just showing you this to note that the
North Pole's at the top so pull at the
bottom and this two-dimensional map
joins around to wrap around your head so
that it's like a sphere but it's
two-dimensional representation as we go
out and look at the Milky Way the Milky
Way is a disc galaxy and this is looking
at it in the same way the band in the
center is in fact what we call the Milky
Way and that's still only a spherical
representation of the Milky Way and a 3d
representation a 3d representation is
given by this here where these are the
stars in spiral arms
the Milky Way disk of the galaxy here's
the Sun and the Dark Matter extends in
some great region all the way around
that is much larger than the visible
galaxy that's what's holding it together
if we go out further and this is not
even too far from cosmic scales this is
the way the structure looks these are
all galaxies each one of them 60,000 of
them and they're all clustered together
into various entities clusters up here
clusters of clusters here filaments
joining the clusters and voids so this
is the structure and as we go further
and further out in the universe we see
that the galaxies patterns like this
continue on and on as far as we can see
changing a bit but as far as we can see
but there comes a time when the galaxies
run out before which there were no
galaxies but as has been referred to in
the introduction what comes to the
rescue here is the remarkable discovery
of the Cosmic Microwave Background in
1965 and the detailed exploration of it
and so I've been involved since 1993
with the Planck Space Telescope which
was designed to look at those signals
from the early moments of the universe
looking at this Cosmic Microwave
Background so the launch one of the
great heartfelt occurrences in my life
was to be at the launch in French Guiana
and your heart is in your gullet or
whatever because all of those years of
effort 16 years could have gone up if
the launch was not successful but it was
successful and Planck has been one of
the most successful of three major
classes of satellites that we've seen
the picture that we released in 2010 was
just a tantalizer showing the complex
emissions of the Milky Way galaxy which
we've already talked about and behind it
is the primordial light that we were
after that was released 13.8 billion
years after the Big Bang 13.8 billion
years ago 380,000 years after the Big
Bang so there are all of these ignitions
that we had to get rid of and sure
enough we did in 2013 we released an
image this is actually the 2015 image
and so we unveiled the sources and these
are tiny little fluctuations in the
intensity or equivalently temperature of
the Cosmic Microwave Background measured
in micro Kelvin so really tiny requiring
tremendous instrumentation and look at
all of the structure that's associated
with this on very large scales and on
very small scales and each one of those
structures has associated with it
characteristic wavelengths and we
analyze this by harmonic analysis much
the same way that you analyze music I
just wanted to quickly refer to the
sequence of satellites that we've had
looking at this radiation one launched
in 1989 called the Coby satellite which
got the Nobel Prize but looked at very
low resolution at the microwave
background an extremely successful
satellite launched in 2001 many people
in the program including me worked on
results from that and then finally this
Planck satellite with much higher
resolution looking at all of these ups
and downs and we look at higher
resolution beyond that from telescopes
that we'll hear about later today on the
ground instead of trying to show you
the details of how we analyze things I
am making the harmonic analysis which is
showing you the different components of
the signal separated into wavelengths
but mapped into just something that
you're hearing and so if you listen to
it
it sounds sort of like noise but it's
clearly got structure and the structures
are associated with the various
characteristics scales of this and we
can take that information and analyze it
in detail and what we learn are things
as I referred to the different contents
of the universe the ordinary matter the
dark matter and the dark energy three
numbers but we can do more than that we
can further unveil the signals and see
what lies below that and it's this is a
map of what lies below that and we can
characterize the structure in that map
of the earliest moments of the universe
by just two numbers and those two
numbers it's a remarkable discovery who
would have thought that in terms of
music the basic and most powerful
discovery of the Planck satellite is
that the sound from the ultra early
universe is like classical music
classical music unlike rock music every
octave is tried to use to maximum amount
so that there are notes in every
frequency and the sound of the universe
from these earliest moments are like
that we have discovered another
fantastic result from Planck is that
there's a little more bass than treble
and the other feature is that it's noise
like so those are all of the celebrated
findings there is one more thing that we
are after we have placed strong
constraints with Planck and other
experiments on this but we're also after
gravitational radiation from the early
universe with this microwave background
radiation looking for the signals there
we'll hear about that this afternoon
it's an exciting frontier of our subject
okay so now to end we have this universe
high degree of simplicity and what
happens if we fast forward with very
large computers and take what we've
learned
about the earliest moments of the
universe and the different kinds of
matter that are present and if we fast
forward it and simulate we find that we
get a universe that looks exactly like
ours it has the characteristic clusters
the super clusters of clusters clustered
together filaments etc voids and so the
great result is that by having unveiled
the simplicity of the universe and
taking that and moving forward with
gravity we have understood the overall
aspect of the universe and I will end
there with a picture of a snake with a
happy smiley face looking back over all
of cosmic time and understanding
everything which is of course what we're
trying to do on the other hand note that
there's a big question mark we certainly
do not understand everything in the
subject in our heart at work thank you
[Applause]